it's no secret that there are a ton of
headphone options out there
and today i partnered with sony to
showcase four of my favorite from their
current lineup and their top features
so here they are we have the wh-1000m4
the wf-1000xm3 the wf
800n and the wf xb700
and i'm just really glad that they
decided to use very simple easy names
for all of these
no they did it but each pair of these
headphones do sound pretty amazing
so i guess we'll let it slide let's
first start with the wh 1000 m4s
i did an entire video dedicated to these
because i love them so much you guys can
check that out if you want but these are
the only over-the-ear headphones that
we're going to be covering today
and they are so impressive for so many
reasons these also work really well with
360 degree audio and if you guys have
never
experienced that before let me tell you
it is a complete game changer so if you
ever do get the opportunity to try it
out if you don't have headphones or a
stereo or something that supports it
definitely try it these headphones are
so great i also love the carrying case
it's got a nice little zipper here this
blue color
is really really pretty they also have a
lighter gray version that are really
awesome as well
they have industry leading noise
cancellation and it is no joke
i actually used to use the m3s when i
used to travel a lot more
last year and i would 100 be in my own
little world on flights
and these new ones have improved noise
cancellation making them even better
than the previous version they have five
microphones for precise
voice pickup and making phone calls of
course they also have this really cool
feature called speak to chat so when you
have this turned on
when you speak the headphones will
automatically know that you're talking
and it'll activate the ambient sound
around you so you're able to have a
conversation they have a 30 hour battery
life and a 10 minute charge will give
you five
hours of battery these are also really
comfortable and i love that they have a
motion sensor that will detect if you're
wearing them or not you can connect two
devices at the same time and they will
automatically switch to whichever you're
using
this is a feature that i cannot stress
enough of how amazing it is because if
you are on your phone or you're on your
computer you have the ability to just
quickly transfer between
each one of those so if i'm on my phone
listening to music and then i start
editing on my laptop
quick switch it's magic the ear cups are
also touch sensitive so that allows you
to have control of all of your media
pause stop
fast forward all of the things there's
also a ton more features in the sony
connect app that will allow you to have
full customization over these
i love the noise canceling little
optimizer that you can do so if i press
start
this will automatically optimize the
atmospheric pressure for
these headphones so it says noise
cancelling optimally
tailored to my tastes and i actually
have speak to chat on
so right now it turned off the noise
cancellation
and i'm hearing myself talk it's pretty
cool can change the sound quality
there's just so many different things
that you can do connect two devices
simultaneously
these are just so great i have used
these for running before but i do prefer
wearing earbuds when i'm running these
are
light enough and comfortable enough that
you can yes
run with these so the difference between
this and the previous version is they
actually
did redesign this headband so it's a
little bit more comfortable
and these cups are actually a little bit
more cushiony they also have
an option here if you want to put a 3.5
millimeter headphone jack this proximity
sensor is also a really cool new feature
in this version
i love the carrying case i love
everything about these definitely
recommend except i'm never good at
putting them back in the case i always
mess it up
perfect these are the wf-1000xm3s
these have the most advanced noise
cancellation ever in wireless headphones
which is pretty cool considering how
small and compact these are i also
really love that this has a usbc
magnetic charging case that will give
you up to 24 hours of noise cancelling
playback on a full charge you'll get
about six hours and if you have the
noise cancelling off and you use these
plus the case
to keep charging you can get up to 32
hours of battery life that's pretty
impressive
also a simple 10 minute charge inside of
the case will give you up to 90 minutes
of play time
i love that these also have proximity
sensors in each earbud so it can detect
if you're wearing one
or both and will be able to adapt the
playback accordingly i sometimes will
take phone calls with just one of these
in so it's great to know that it's
adapting to how i'm using them
the adaptive sound control will
automatically adjust to whatever you're
doing so if you're traveling or walking
or just hanging out at home
this can adjust the ambient sound to fit
that situation one of my top features
and favorite things about these
headphones is the noise cancellation
they are very small
compact you can get great battery life
and just being able to activate the
noise cancellation in these
quite an added bonus and i really like
this color it's actually a very nice
gold and tan
you can also connect these to the
headphone connect app which will give
you some more access to some controls
so let's get you all paired up once you
have them connected much like the m4s
that we just talked about this also
gives you various controls that you can
change like the ambient sound there's
also a really cool feature where you can
analyze your ear shape
inside of the headphone app so what this
does is it's able to tailor
the audio to your ear shape yeah i know
that's pretty futuristic so here's where
you can change the ambient sound control
or the playback control you can choose
the left or the right
automatic power off and all kinds of
other fun things
they're doing a little update that's one
of the really cool things about
headphones like this that are able to
connect to apps is you are able to
easily give them
updates right over the air i've always
actually really loved these headphones
because
they stay in my ears really well and i
love that they have
these as little added extras they have
rubber and silicone tips which you can
decide
which works better for you so far it
seems like
the ones that came with these are
working quite well oh
the ambient sound has just turned on
hello it's me let's
listen to a little song shall we ambient
sound is off
noise cancellation is am i yelling i
think i'm yelling
i'm listening to music i can't let you
hear it because it's copy written
sounds so good the fit of these is
actually really nice okay i don't pause
my music the thing that i've always
loved about these
is how comfortable they are i know a lot
of times some of these types of in-ear
headphones don't work for a lot of
people
so it is really great to know that they
have a wide variety of options
basically to hopefully cover all of
their bases for everybody's ear shape
these are the wf sp 800 and these are
the headphones that i'd recommend most
for anyone who is into running or any
other type of sport
these are ip55 rated for water and dust
resistance so with this rating you're
safe to rinse them off after a workout
or
if you accidentally drop an earbud in
the dust when you're hiking like i've
done before
so these also have 360 reality audio
support which is really exciting it's
cool because this gives the artists
a way to really make you feel how they
want you to feel when you're listening
to the music it's kind of like an
immersive
360 experience so the artists are able
to place instruments
in sort of like this 360 space is able
to give you
the impression that you're at a live
show or you're on stage so wherever you
happen to be in space they're able to
dictate that
to you these also have the quick
attention feature so if you place your
finger
over the earbud it'll turn the volume
down and it'll let in the ambient sound
now i usually do keep this turned on for
outdoor runs so i'm able to hear cars
coming up next to me each earbud will
perform a different action so you can
determine
which is which inside of the app the
thing that i really like about these
ones
is they have this little hook right here
so this gives you
a little bit more of i guess support if
you are doing very active things
so that just kind of hooks around the
inner part of your ear oh gosh
it's talking to me it's talking to me
hello are you there
these types of in-ear headphones usually
work the best because i do sometimes
need that little extra
speaking of extra they've also got a
couple extra sizes too
so if you're not a fan of these little
hooks you can
switch those out for just the little
earbud types
i'm loving this light blue theme that
we've got going on here
ambient sound i can hear everything
around me i just love being able to have
the touch controls right on your ears
like i don't even have to go to my phone
i can play my music i just gotta
and now i'm back listening to my
favorite artists
of which i won't mention because it
might be copyrighted
[Music]
so to give you one guess what the key
feature is on these
extra face they also have a really long
lasting 18 hour battery life with quick
charge much like some of the other
headphones we've talked about they do
give you some extra tips to get a
perfect fit
i also really like how small this case
is it's much smaller than some of the
other cases that we've talked about
these are also water resistant which is
very nice because i'm quite
reckless with all of the things so it is
really nice to know that
these can stand a little bit of water
these also have little buttons on the
side so this will let you do things like
play stop skip tracks or adjust the
volume
or just even have access to your phone's
voice assistant for hands-free calls
i hope this gives you a little clarity
on the differences between all four of
these pairs of headphones there are a
lot of options out there so if you are
looking to get a gift for someone this
holiday season or
just a gift for yourself these cover a
wide variety of price ranges
and activities let me know if you guys
have any questions in the comments below
and have you guys tried any of these
have you ever tried 360 reality audio
because if you haven't
that is something that i recommend
putting on your to-do list for 2021.